[Music]
Captain Marvel is currently setting big
records at the box office and whilst
reaction to the film has been mixed it's
clear that it's provided a talking point
not only about modern cinema but also at
inclusivity as a whole coming in at just
over two hours the film is one of the
shortest Marvel movies in recent memory
so it's clear that there's been a lot
left on the cutting-room floor this
includes Yann Rob and Ronin meeting
Captain Marvel and the answer to one of
the biggest questions in the film who
does Yan rock see as the supreme
intelligence so I thought I'd put
together a breakdown of what the answer
reveals and why it was missing from the
movie this is full spoilers ahead for
the film so if you haven't seen Captain
Marvel yet you may want to skip this
video until you've had a chance to watch
it without the way I'm definition and
welcome to the channel where I explain
it so you don't have to the supreme
intelligence plays a big part in Captain
Marvel and it's pretty much the movies
Big Bad the AI intelligence is the
leader of the Kree and is seen as a God
by the citizens of power the
intelligence is manipulative in every
way and even takes the form of the
person are the onlooker most respects so
that it will be trusted similar to the
scrolls the intelligence is able to
transform to fit its needs and this is a
big point of contention in the film to
the point that it's even viewed as
sacrilege to tell others which form it
takes one of the big questions that many
may have when leaving the film is who
does Yan Roxy well this question was
actually answered in the film in one of
its deleted scenes brandon us who worked
on the film stated on reddit that an
entire sequence i worked on the VFX 4
was cut when yan raw has a chat with the
supreme intelligence before he gets sent
to go find carroll and the tesseract
I'm waiting for my output from the movie
to show up to see if they have any of
the original supreme intelligence
concepts in there when asked who young
rogue saw Brannan stated it was himself
I actually left the film thinking that
this may be the case
raagh is of course massively
self-assured and in his mind even more
power
and Captain Marvel so it makes sense
that this arrogance and ego would carry
over into the intelligence though he
never stated why the scene was cut Kevin
Feige in a recent interview with
comicbook.com said there was only a
conversation we're telling carol danvers
origin story and this was her origin
story and her origin story was focused
on her growth and the female friends and
mentors and inspirations around her many
have taken from this that the scenes
involving the Kree were cut as they
ultimately turn out to be the big bad of
the film and leaving them in would
perhaps make them seem more sympathetic
it makes a lot of sense and hopefully
this scene will be included on the
blu-ray and DVD release that is sure to
come later this year obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on this scene and
what you took from it are you surprised
at the revelation and what other
questions would you like answered from
the film comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the full film which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it subscribe thanks again
to take the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you